oh
[Music]
come on
i need
[Music]
foreign
find your dad
[Music]
nagasa
[Music]
kanga in swahili means shield
kinga is a program for selling
contraceptives to the main of kenya
through the dukas
small general stores which sell everyday
needs
the men who sell the condoms bearing
this name travel in two trucks
the first truck to enter the village is
white for the advanced information man
who distributes promotional material and
samples
the pink truck is driven by the salesman
who distributes supplies of condoms to
the lucas
as part of a program sponsored by the
government of kenya
they sell the condoms at a low
subsidized price
but the king of men do more than sell
to their pills
[Music]
he answers questions and dispels
confusion
he talks about the whole range of
contraceptive methods
including those the women for can use
the pills and iuds
they concentrate on the condoms which
give the responsibility for family
planning to the man
by using the kanga
the shield
the man retains the image of virility
and strength
that he associates with the tradition of
his forefathers
the condoms can be bought for a few
pennies whatever the men buy tobacco and
other personal needs
[Music]
it is not necessary for the men to visit
doctors or clinics together
most of the men know by now
that they need not have more babies than
they can properly care for
by helping them to buy a contraceptive
method cheaply and easily
in locations they visit frequently
the kanga program is making the whole
process not only simpler but more
dignified
something which suits the man of kenya
well
the government wants a prosperous
healthy nation
the men who lead kenya believe that
family planning is one way to reach this
goal
mr minister family planning
is
a relevant issue in matters of planning
in relation to vehicular what's your
views on this
well my views which really are
government views
is that family planning is an integral
part
of development planning
it is an essential part for the reason
that you cannot hope to plan other forms
of production if you cannot plan the
production of the main
resource the human beings
we view it as an aspect of human freedom
in the same way as we give people
education
so as to open wider horizons for them in
the world
the same way that you provide a farmer
with greater knowledge about the seed
while fertility of the soil about
climate about rotation of crops
it's the same way that you must provide
that information that education
to the person
so that he is not
restricted in his living by ignorance so
that he becomes aware that there is a
way there are methods of regulating his
family
there are means of spacing the birth of
his children so that is not slave to
just natural forces and this is what i
said in swahili to these people that we
view
family planning education
as an extension of personal liberty the
man the woman are then able to make
personal decision a family decision as
to when they want their children how
many they want
it is not a program for government to
force people to restrict the numbers or
even as to how to space their children
it is a program to give them the
knowledge with the knowledge and as a
free people we know they will make the
right decision which is that they want
healthy children they will therefore
want to space them so that they can feed
them better educate them them better
close them better and then we shall have
a healthier nation this is what we want
to do
another man of kenya sees the matter in
homelear more personal terms
i've been now tour guide in this tour
guide business for about five years
always and uh
this time i'm just married at an age of
28 and
i want to plant my birth
my my family
to an extent of two children
because
um
this is a new system in a in a young
country of kenya and it's a well-planned
person
of course one should plan everything so
[Music]
i think it would be alright to plan it
uh two children
which i'll be able to
look after in the best way
i guess that's a nice thing altogether
it is men such as this who benefit from
programs such as kanga
programs aimed at their intelligence
their self-interest
their belief in the future
[Music]
if in time a kenya father upon dividing
his land between his children
can see that he has enough land for them
because he has only two sons
if the people can think calmly of their
future not as something which happens by
good chance
but something which comes of a quiet
plan
then one day
they can look at the dear land of king
and be proud
the old ones walk by the road and dream
of all days
the young ones go in the sunlight and
dream of days to come
of the richness of our land the blue
mountains and the forests and valleys
where wild creatures roam
these are our blessed heritage
these we must nourish and guard for our
children
so that our land lives forever
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
you